while since you guys have been on the
draft floor yeah it was uh
you know a little different for the
first little while I think
we hadn't uh been in this format for a
while
we've kind of gotten used to being in a
war room and easy to talk freely and you
don't really have to be careful with
your list as much and it's just a
different Dynamic but uh you know
Montreal did such a great job and it I
guess it keeps it reminds you of why we
why we do it it's such a fan friendly
event and it's something unique to our
league cool for the prospects to get
this experience and that too yeah yeah
you know I think kids look at this and
it's something they dream of we had Alex
gedenix son Krill as a runner and I know
that's a dream of his is to be you know
in the future his name be called and be
at a draft like this you you moved up a
couple times
um just was it was it in the case of
guys falling further than you thought
they were going to uh not really I think
you just you put your list together and
you know there's certain and layers that
we put into it and we say if we can move
up in this layer and do it for the value
we think's fairer than we do it and you
kind of you kind of do a little bit more
quality over quantity a little bit too
if you wait too long sometimes that
layer we call gets obliterated and then
you're into a different layer of players
so you know we did it with the Gustafson
Jordan we really we really like he was a
layer on our list and we said uh
when we were going through it with
Matthias in Lair and then Jordan Gustin
and Lair if we we thought if we could
get two players uh though in those in
those layers uh and above on our list
would be a pretty good day to start so
it seems like from the scattered reports
that Jordan His skating is really a
strength is that
about everything everything about him
he's a two-way player a big engine plays
uh all three four positions uh plays
both specialty teams and he did that as
a 17 year old on a very good Seattle
team and it's they're going to have a
real good team again next year
his brother plays in Red Deer is six
foot three
we think there's a chance he could grow
a little bit I don't know if he'll get
six three but his brother grew late as
well so there's a lot to like about him
I think he's got character he's got a
very good two-way game
you know we were just really like the
versatility and the leadership that he
brings he was up for Cameron Whitehead
too what do you like well we had him uh
rated as one of the top goalies on our
list I think uh we it much like we did
with Vickman
uh we just had him read it high we just
felt if uh if in that area if we could
get him in that area as a good uh we
have two thirds next year
so we could flip our fourth from next
year to this year and and maximize I
think value for that so that's what we
looked at there you woke up this morning
you didn't have a pick last night that
was probably pretty hard on you to sit
there and watch players that get scouted
all year you get here this morning and
Matthias is is there when you get there
where your eyes big yeah we were excited
uh you know it's funny you do your
you do all your mock drafts or all your
preparation and there's certain players
that
with you know all the Intel that we had
could be available and we're really
excited if you could be available at you
know one time we talked about maybe
possibly moving up for him we just felt
with the way it gone the first night you
sit down after the first night and you
look at the group of names you have left
we just said let's be patient at 48. our
our thing was be patient at 48 we'll get
a guy we like and let's do something
with 95 let's move up from 95 and our
our strategy worked I think
seen a lot of Matthias uh we all have
you know Saginaw I started with the
Linka with the checks but then he came
over playing Saginaw
played 20 minutes a night played all
situations uh
you know there's still a lot he's a very
raw Prosper very tall lean Prospect our
Sports Science people think there's a
lot to work with there we think he's
really going to pop offensively there
were some nights where his and even when
we talked to him about this at the
combine he just ran out of ran out of
gas because he's playing both specialty
teams every night 20 over 20 I think
it's close to 22 minutes a night for a
first year Ford from Europe that hasn't
played that games didn't play much the
year before so uh you know there's
there's lots of Runway there and we just
feel that uh you know in two years he's
going to be big strong really good
two-way forward
first time in a long time some of these
guys you haven't seen them on the ice at
CNA how excited are you yeah really
excited that and uh and you look a
little bit further in the rookie
tournament we did have that last year
but
uh development Camp is going to be good
for us but really good for the players
we got some kids that we drafted haven't
been able to be at a a live development
Camp they've done some virtual stuff and
I think just being live uh being able to
work with them seeing them on the ice as
a group but I think it's really exciting
are there any players today that you're
particularly excited to see guys that
you draft for maybe a year or two ago
that have developed really nicely since
you picked him well brassonne Moore's
off guys like that who have been a
little bit harder like them playing in
the rookie tournament too is very
another step too I think it's going to
be really exciting I think we are
you know our group of forwards for the
rookie tournament are going to be very
very deep and exciting Zach Dean you
know we gotta you know two European
players we took last year with Annex and
and damage our
yeah and those you guys are going to be
real good to see you next time
you know that's going to be hard because
his last year he didn't get any love I
think he got beat up a little bit I
think uh
he just didn't uh
uh have much of a year development and I
think uh we're you know really looking
forward for him I guess just giving him
opportunity to play in a lot of
different situations I think it starts
with the rookie tournament which I think
is a very good level of hockey and very
challenging so
Patrick gay it's hard to produce that
any guy that has 100 points in uh in a
major Junior Hockey it's a big season he
had 104. what do you like about him uh
goal scoring uh 55 goals very big he
plays bigger than his size uh one of the
top players in Charlottetown had a very
good playoff as well too you know it's
funny he's a he's a kid that we
talked about in his draft year the two
years previous and if you look at his
progression if we would have drafted him
we would have been pretty happy with
where he was with a 19 year old so I
think in the fifth round
I was in Ottawa and we took Mike Hoffman
who had similar numbers
similar age in that similar spot and
ended up you know he's playing in NHL as
as uh you know with the goal scoring and
everything like that that you know he's
he's got for a five the smaller players
what you need from them is their compete
and he has he has uh he has big heart
and works very very hard does she go to
the net he goes in that hard and uh he
can score from a distance or score
around the net and very good metrics he
had and we're uh we were just excited we
were going to see burbanich all the time
and he just kept popping off the and you
just kind of do your homework and we
kind of knew we we actually had him come
in a development Camp if he goes through
the draft but we just are in knowing
what we knew he wasn't going to go
through the draft so we thought it was a
good investment so
anybody else that you know that kind of
was that special like you said like you
know you knew that you wanted Matthias
when you came here this morning was
there another guy that kind of popped
out for you like dated that you were
kind of if we can get him we'll grab him
the hammerling kid was very exciting as
well too we have them quite high on our
list and we had talked extensively about
him in our meetings and to have him
where we got him and the six dollars was
very good value and Everett has a real
good program they do a very good job of
turning up players he's an old four that
played you know on the bets well they
had the best record they got beat in the
first round because of injuries but
plays a lot like the Gustin kid the
certain minutes that he plays and plays
all over their lineup in different
positions I think we're excited about
him as well I got a text from someone in
the western right away saying I like
hammerling at that spot so
he's a good that's a good slot for him
to get him there yes yeah we were very
excited uh we you know it's funny as the
as the drafts unfolding you got the guy
on your list and you're sitting there
looking at him you're hoping he doesn't
get picked and we know what happens all
the time he was the guy in the six that
we were sitting there waiting crossing
our fingers and we're really happy to
get him